[Música]
buenas tardes tengo que confesarle salud
pero antes me gustaría pedirles un favor
que me hagan ustedes una pequeña
confesión amigo cuánta gente de esta
sala estima que lleva un estilo de vida
saludable manos arriba por favor
se podían dar aquí tres circunstancias
la primera que sea mitad mitad
fifty-fifty como se suele decir que es
lo que acaba de pasar la segunda que
todo el mundo tuviera la mano levantada
y que fuera ya esto un contexto ideal o
la tercera que nadie hubiera levantado
la mano y ya me piro a casa no tengo una
vacación
pues como les decía tengo que
confesarles algo
se ha descubierto una píldora que les va
a ayudar a tener una vida más saludable
pero os lo voy a ir contando poco a poco
que yo esté aquí hoy hablándoles es una
de esas muchas locuras de felipe
benditas locuras que un día me dice te
apetece dar una pequeña charla en el
télex de mondoñedo y yo sí claro
encantado soy un buen o un fan de estas
charlas y le digo y de qué tengo que
hablar me dice el tema principal es la
desintoxicación
vale
la desintoxicación de mi cara y dice
pero nada relacionado con lo que tú
haces como profesor con la actividad
física el deporte la educación física
concepto clave educación física no
gimnasia y no me empiecen a decir que es
lo mismo es como si a las matemáticas le
llamasen mos sumas por ejemplo que hasta
el hijo de mi prima de cinco años lo
tiene clarísimo les cuesta les cuento
una anécdota un martes cualquiera en
coruña va a mi madre a recoger al peque
a la salida del cole y le dice hola
mickey qué tal qué guapo estás hoy y ese
chándal tuviste gimnasia
respuesta de miguel notita gimnasia no
indicación física así que bueno por lo
menos indicación física vale gimnasia no
y siguiendo con el tema de la
desinformación actividad física vida
saludable etc podría traerles aquí
cientos de estudios investigaciones
noticias consejos de la organización
mundial de la salud o de muchos otros
profesionales que nos hablan de la
creciente preocupación por la tasa de
obesidad y de sedentarismo en nuestra
sociedad sobre todo en los niños y en
los jóvenes pero no puedo estaría
infoxicación los así que voy a hacerles
una serie de preguntas se les ocurre a
ustedes una forma mejor para salir del
estrés del exceso de información del
ritmo frenético de la vida diaria que ir
a darse un paseo por el campo oa correr
o en bici
a hacer surf solo con la familia con un
amigo con la pareja con el perro como se
les ocurra
en cuanto a alimentación me pueden decir
ustedes algún tipo de comida más
saludable y más rica que la que hacían
nuestras abuelas la comida real la de
siempre sin tener que buscar información
y más información entre infinidad de
ingredientes del resto de alimentos
como creen ustedes que estarán más
alegres que tendrá un mejor día si
tienen un descanso diario de 78 horas o
si lo interrumpen o lo cortan por culpa
de andar un poquito a deshora con redes
sociales un poquito de trabajo a deshora
por la noche
y de desplazamientos si tenemos que ir
de un sitio a otro una distancia que sea
que se pueda realizar andando como
piensan que van a estar más activos pues
se van a sentir mejor con ustedes mismos
más alegres más más libres si lo
realizamos andando o si siempre lo
realizamos en coche
en bus o med y mientras esperamos ese
bus y es el metro otro poquito redes
sociales y otro poquito de información
extra y por qué no otro poquito de
trabajo a deshoras
y ya por último si tienen un poquito de
tiempo libre una hora dos horas una
mañana una tarde como la emplean será
mejor con los amigos o con la familia
haciendo una actividad al aire libre por
las calles e inmediaciones de mondoñedo
por ejemplo o nos quedamos en casa
encerrados como otro poquito de redes
sociales como no vale la información
extra
pues veamos
el llevar un estilo de vida saludable es
una opción que podemos elegir que
debemos elegir para ir acabando me gusta
destacar una frase que trato de inculcar
en mi alumnado y que dice que no hay que
hacer actividad física para darle años a
la vida sino para darle vida a los años
a hilo de la píldora que no olvidaba si
ustedes van a la farmacia y hay una
píldora que reduce el estrés previene el
axé de la ansiedad y la depresión
fortalece los músculos fortalece los
huesos nos ayuda a socializar a ser más
empáticos a tener más autonomía previene
enfermedades cardiovasculares mejora la
circulación sanguínea la compraría en
verdad
actividad física estilo de vida
saludable ustedes eligen muchas gracias
[Aplausos]